>>> HELLO AND THANKS FOR BEING
HERE.
I'M ANA CABRERA IN NEW YORK.
AUTHORITIES ARE QUESTIONING THE
PARENTS OF THE PARENTS OF
BLAUNDRY.
WE SEE THE FBI ESCORTING THE
FAMILY.
THE COUPLE HAD DOCUMENTED THEIR
TRAVELS ACROSS SEVERAL WESTERN
STATES ON SOCIAL MEDIA, WELL,
THAT STOPPED SHORTLY BEFORE
LAUNDRIE RETURNED HOME ALONE ON
SEPTEMBER 1st.
CNN CORRESPONDENT LAILA SANTIAGO
IS ON THE SCENE IN FLORIDA.
WHAT'S HAPPENING THERE, LAILA,
RIGHT NOW.
>> Reporter: RIGHT NOW, ANA, IN
THE HOME BEHIND ME WHERE THE
COUPLE LIVED AND WHERE THE
PARENTS OF BRIAN LAUNDRIE ARE AT
THIS HOUR WE UNDERSTAND FBI
AGENTS ARE QUESTIONING THE
PARENTS AND THIS IS NOW ABOUT
THE THIRD HOUR THAT THEY HAVE
BEEN DOING THAT.
WE WERE HERE WHEN A CARAVAN OF
CARS PULLED IN.
THEY -- THEY SURROUNDED THE
HOME, CALLED OUT THAT THEY HAD A
SEARCH WARRANT, WENT INSIDE.
THE PARENTS CAME OUTSIDE.
THEY EXECUTED THE SEARCH WARRANT
AND THEN BROUGHT THEM BACK IN
FOR QUESTIONING.
A LOT OF CRITICAL QUESTIONS
REMAIN TO GET SOME BIG ANSWERS
AS TO WHAT HAPPENED HERE.
THE BIG ONE BEING WHERE IS BRIAN
LAUNDRIE?
LET'S BACK UP FOR A MINUTE TO
TALK ABOUT HOW WE GOT HERE.
REMEMBER, OVER THE WEEKEND THERE
WAS QUITE A SEARCH IN A
25,000-ACRE WILDLIFE RESERVE
BECAUSE THE PARENTS OF BRIAN
LAUNDRIE TOLD POLICE THAT THEY
HADN'T SEEN HIM SINCE TUESDAY
SAYING THAT THE LAST TIME THEY
SAW HIM, THEY CLAIM HE HAD A
HIKING BACKPACK ON AND HE WAS
HEADING OVER TO THAT RESERVE FOR
A HIKE.
THAT CLAIM WAS MADE TO POLICE ON
FRIDAY, SO THAT'S WHAT SET OFF
THAT SEARCH FOR BRIAN LAUNDRIE
AFTER DAYS THAT HIS FAMILY
CLAIMED THEY HAVEN'T SEEN HIM
AND THEY WERE CONCERNED ABOUT
HIS WELL-BEING AND HIS
WHEREABOUTS.
BUT ANOTHER BIG THING HAPPENED
OVER THE WEEKEND.
YOU MENTIONED IT, ANA, SUNDAY.
WE HEARD FROM FBI IN WYOMING
SAYING THAT THEY HAD BEEN
SEARCHING UP THERE FOR GABBY
PETITO, AND THEN WE LEARNED FROM
THE CORONER IN THE AREA THAT
THEY FOUND A BODY WITH
CHARACTERISTICS THAT WERE
CONSISTENT WITH GABBY PETITO,
THE FAMILY ALSO BEING NOTIFIED
AND NOW ASKING FOR PRIVACY.
SO QUITE A BIT OF DEVELOPMENTS
ALMOST DAILY HERE WITH THIS
STORY, BUT THE -- THE BIG
QUESTION REMAINS WHERE IS BRIAN
LAUNDRIE?
POLICE ARE TRYING TO FIND HIM
RATHER HOPING THAT THAT COULD
GIVE THEM ANSWERS AS TO WHAT
HAPPENED HERE.
NOW, WE EXPECT TOMORROW THAT WE
COULD GET SOME MORE ANSWERS
BECAUSE WE COULD SEE THE RESULTS
FROM THE AUTOPSY REPORT FROM THE
BODY THAT WAS FOUND ON SUNDAY IN
THE GRAND TETON NATIONAL PARK,
ANA.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
THEY HAVE NOT GIVEN US A CAUSE
OF DEATH AT THIS POINT.
AGAIN, STILL WAITING ON THAT
100% CONFIRMATION THAT THAT BODY
IS INDEED GABBY PETITO.
LAILA SANTIAGO, THANK YOU.
PLEASE KEEP US UPDATED.
FOR MORE PERSPECTIVE ON THE
INVESTIGATION CNN SENIOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT ANALYST AND FORMER
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE FBI
ANDREW McCABE IS WITH US NOW.
FIRST, END, THE FBI AND FLORIDA
POLICE, THEY ARE EXECUTING THE
SEARCH WARRANT TODAY AT
LAUNDRIE'S HOME.
WHAT ARE THEY LOOKING FOR?
>> WELL, ANA, THERE'S ALL KINDS
OF PIECES OF EVIDENCE THAT COULD
BE IN THAT HOUSE, AND LET'S
REMEMBER THAT BRIAN LAUNDRIE
ALLEGEDLY RETURNED TO THE HOUSE
ON SEPTEMBER 1st.
HIS PARENTS REPORTED ON FRIDAY
THE 17th THAT HE HAD BEEN
MISSING SINCE TUESDAY THE 14th
SO HE'S IN THAT HOUSE FOR TWO
WEEKS BEFORE HE GOES MISSING.
PRIMARILY WHAT THE INVESTIGATORS
WILL BE LOOKING FOR IS ANYTHING
HE MAY HAVE WRITTEN, ANY
RECORDINGS OF HIS -- OF HIS
THOUGHTS, OF HIS -- IF HE WROTE
ANY NOTES, IF HE KEPT A JOURNAL.
CERTAINLY ANY ACTIVITY THAT HE
MIGHT HAVE PERFORMED ON COMPUTER
DEVICES SO THOSE ARE CELL
PHONES, TABLETS, DESKTOP
COMPUTERS, ANYTHING THAT COULD
ACCESS THE INTERNET, THAT COULD
SHOW SEARCHES THAT HE MAY HAVE
PERFORMED, THINGS OF THAT
NATURE.
I'M SURE ALL OF THOSE DEVICES
ARE EITHER BEING SEIZED OR
MIRRORED ON SITE WHERE THEY TAKE
ESSENTIALLY A COPY OF EVERYTHING
THAT'S ON THAT MACHINE AND THEN
THEY CAN GO BACK AND ANALYZE
THAT STUFF IN THE LAB LATER.
THEY WILL BE LOOKING FOR
FORENSIC EVIDENCE.
ANYTHING THAT HE MIGHT HAVE HAD
WITH HIM ON THAT TRIP THAT THEY
MIGHT WANT TO LOOK AT FOR HAIR
HAND FIBER EVIDENCE, FOR
POTENTIALLY BLOOD SPATTER OR
OTHER, YOU KNOW, OTHER
BIOLOGICAL EVIDENCE.
THERE'S ALL KINDS OF THINGS THAT
MIGHT BE IN THERE.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT'S IN THERE
YET BUT WE SHOULD FIND OUT AT
SOME POINT IN THE FUTURE.
>> CERTAINLY MORE QUESTIONS THAN
ANSWERS ON MANY FRONTS AT THIS
HOUR, BUT WE DO KNOW LAUNDRIE
RETURNED TO THIS HOUSE ON
SEPTEMBER 1st WITHOUT GABBY
PETITO, SO THAT IS NOW ALMOST
THREE WEEKS AGO.
WHY WAIT UNTIL NOW TO TAKE THIS
STEP WITH THIS SEARCH WARRANT?
>> WELL, THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION.
YOU KNOW, THERE ARE -- OF
COURSE, LAUNDRIE IS NOT A
SUBJECT IN A CRIME, RIGHT, WE
THINK HE'S LIKELY ONE OF THE
LAST PEOPLE TO HAVE SEEN GABBY
PETITO ALIVE SO HE'S AN
IMPORTANT WITNESS.
HE'S SOMEONE THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT WANTED TO TALK TO
HIM AND THEY WERE TOLD BY THE
FAMILY THAT LAUNDRIE DIDN'T WANT
TO SPEAK AND REFERRED THEM TO AN
ATTORNEY.
YOU'RE ALWAYS GOING TO MAKE AN
EFFORT TO APPROACH A WITNESS AND
TALK WITH THEM ON A COOPERATIVE
BASIS THAT.
CLEARLY WAS NOT HAPPENING HERE
RIGHT AWAY.
DIDN'T HAPPEN AT ALL, AND SO
WE'RE AT POINT NOW WHERE THE
SEARCH WARRANT ABSOLUTELY HAS TO
BE EXECUTED.
WE STILL DON'T KNOW IF -- IF
BRIAN LAUNDRIE HAD ANY SORT OF
INVOLVEMENT IN HER DEATH.
WE SHOULD LEARN MORE FROM THE
AUTOPSY REPORT, BUT THERE'S A
LOT OF INVESTIGATION LEFT TO DO
HERE, ANA.
>> I JUST DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW
THIS KEY PERSON IN THIS
INVESTIGATION COULD GO MISSING
MISSING NOW.
HOW DOES THAT HAPPEN?
>> WELL, AS THE FAMILY SAID OVER
THE WEEKEND, IS HE MISSING OR IS
HE HIDING?
DID HE GO FOR A HIKE OR FLEE THE
AREA?
ALL OF THAT STUFF STARTS TO LOOK
MUCH MORE SUSPICIOUS AT THIS
POINT.
IT SOUNDS LIKE LAW ENFORCEMENT
DID ACTUALLY RECOVER THE VEHICLE
EARLIER ON IN THIS SAGA, LIKE
MAYBE LAST WEEK OR THE WEEK
BEFORE AND EXECUTED SOME SORT OF
A SEARCH IN THAT VEHICLE LOOKING
FOR EVIDENCE, SO IT'S CLEAR THAT
THEY HAVE BEEN KIND OF NARROWING
THEIR FOCUS ON LAUNDRIE AS THEY
HAVE BEEN GOING ALONG, BUT HE
SOMEHOW MANAGED TO SLIP OUT OF
THEIR VISION.
MUST NOT HAVE BEEN UNDER
SURVEILLANCE OR ANYTHING OF THAT
TUREAND NOW THAT IS THE
PRIME QUESTION IN THIS QUESTION.
WHERE IS MR. LAUNDRIE AND WHEN
CAN WE GET IN FRONT OF HIM?
>> SO GABBY PETITO, SHE WAS A
TRAVEL INFLUENCER.
SHE WAS DOCUMENTING THEIR TRAVEL
ON YOUTUBE.
THAT'S PART OF THE REASON THAT
THIS CASE CAUGHT SO MUCH
ATTENTION NATIONWIDE.
INVESTIGATORS HAVE RECEIVED
HUNDREDS IF NOT THOUSAND OF TIPS
FROM THE PUBLIC ABOUT THIS.
DO YOU THINK SOCIAL MEDIA HAS
HELPED OR HINDERED THIS
INVESTIGATION?
>> WELL, I THINK IT'S PROBABLY
HELPED BRING ATTENTION TO THIS
CASE.
I MEAN, LET'S REMEMBER THOUSANDS
AND THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE GO
MISSING EVERY -- EVERY YEAR IN
THIS COUNTRY AND VERY FEW OF
THEM GET KIND OF ATTENTION FROM
THE PUBLIC AND FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT QUITE FRANKLY THAT
MISS PETITO HAS MANAGED TO
GENERATE.
I'M SURE SOME THAT HAVE IS
BECAUSE SO MANY PEOPLE WERE
FOLLOWING HER STORY ON SOCIAL
MEDIA.
IT'S PROBABLY ALSO MORE LIKELY
NOW THAT INDIVIDUALS WILL
RECOGNIZE HAVING INTERACTED WITH
MR. LAUNDRIE AS WE'VE HAD ONE
REPORT TODAY OF A COUPLE WHO
ALLEGEDLY PICKED HIM UP AND GAVE
HIM A RIDE AS A HITCH-HIKER
SOMEWHERE OUT WEST IN THE DAYS
THAT HE LIKELY LEFT THE GRAND
TETON SO EXPECT MORE STORIES
LIKE THAT TO ARISE AND THOSE
THINGS ARE PROBABLY LIKELY DUE
TO THE ATTENTION T